we we've had uh several segments talking
about the reporting you've done and
wikipedia yeah so when i pull up the
wikipedia it's horrible
oh it's beyond it
it's it's insane it's uh but i'm gonna
read some because it's important they
say project veritas is an american far
right activist group founded by james
o'keefe the group produces deceptively
edited videos of its undercover
operations which use secret recordings
in an effort to discredit mainstream
media organizations and progressive
groups project veritas also uses
entrepreneurs to generate bad publicity
for its targets and has propagated
disinformation and conspiracy theories
in its videos and operations now there's
a couple things i want to say
all of the citations on this are opinion
pieces yes
yes wikipedia is an encyclopedia it says
this whole article has taken random
opinions and it was funny because i was
looking at the talk section on wikipedia
where the editors talk and someone said
why are we using all of these op-eds
it's not it's not what was the response
to that guy oh they get shut down in two
seconds
but you want to know this is why i just
said to you i want you to sue wikipedia
because there's something very important
right above that that that paragraph i
just read yeah it says from wikipedia oh
it doesn't say from
usercatlover42 it doesn't say from
johnny b good 900 it doesn't say from we
are change it says from wikipedia right
here they banned me on wikipedia so i'm
not on there that's very it says they
said they said from wikipedia what do
you mean from wikipedia
it says at the top of the site project
veritas from wikipedia the free
encyclopedia project veritas is
if they're asserting the statements have
come from themselves that's a good point
it doesn't matter so i'll put it this
way we launched himcast.com we got a
bunch of users it's going really well we
have journalists
could i take random comments from users
quote block the text and then put it in
an article that says from tim cast or
from tim poole right and then assert oh
it's user-generated content we're 230
protected
no i've put my byline on it wikipedia
has asserted this is their statements
from them yes now if they can they can
remove that but i think as as long as
that exists and they have asserted this
on this page about veritas nowhere does
it say the statements came from any
journalists any writers any pundits
opinion people or users it only says
from wikipedia i i think that's a great
fact i will talk to my lawyers about
that but i do intend to sue wikipedia in
some way matter shape or form
and i will do that whether it's the
users the website will do it but it's
very important your audience understand
this i know you do you said they're all
citing opinion pieces and and that in
the new york times lawsuit tim the new
york state supreme court judge actually
said how deceptive it was for the new
york times reporter to mask uh a first
sentence of the article and defended it
saying that's my opinion and that was
deceptive and that was disinformation
the judge actually said it was
disinformation for the new york times to
call it an opinion when it was
used
to justify all types of other things but
they use supposition they use circular
sources this is the way the propaganda
works i admire
these writers on wikipedia and the new
york times you have to be an artist
to to paint reality in the way that they
do
it's it's any any time i aim a camera in
any direction it will contradict what
you see
on that page and that's why people are
so pissed off that's why the
whistleblowers are coming out because
listen people are going to give up their
livelihoods right now
i've spent my whole life effectively
doing this since i was in college for
you know 15 16 years and you might have
one or two people a year that say okay
i'll do it right now 10 000 people are
willing to do it
that's the silver lining people are
waking up and sometimes maybe it has to
be darkest before the you know the light
you know when i was looking at the uh
the pfizer scientists video you did it
some of them seemed like that one guy i
think his name was nick carl right yep
and he seemed like he he was reveling in
it yeah mandated do it but one of those
guys i think the guy's name was chris or
whatever seemed kind of like
i know what's going on is bad yeah i'm
not a fan of this
but they're not willing to
nobody wants nobody wants to stick their
neck out nobody wants to take the
responsibility of what it means that
they're a snowflake contributing to this
avalanche yeah we talked about this last
time it's it takes a lot of courage to
to stick your neck out but in the 20th
century people didn't really have
as many options and and these days that
you know you can put a goat you know not
go funny because they banned us on
gofundme
give son go raising half a million
dollars per whistleblower half a million
dollars for whistleblower now at project
veritas i i'd say i think what like 10
years ago that was that was near
retirement funds but now with inflation
through the room you're lucky to buy and
one more comment i want to make about
how journalism has changed i'm seeing
this a new phenomenon occur the
mainstream media will now not reveal
newsworthy information due to the quote
harm
the information might inflict on the
subject exposed remember the communist
teacher thing we did a month ago
gabrielle gaip in california with the
com
oh yeah yeah
yeah this guy was saying we you know
talking about child abuse and we need to
scare scare the f out of kids and a lot
of the people in sacramento had to
report on this because he was fired so
they had to report the news
but one of the refrains was they're not
going to mention the name of the teacher
listen to this quote teacher whose name
we are not disclosing
due to a potential harm against him wow
so this is a new phenomenon in
journalism we're not going to reveal
news with information because the person
might be harmed same thing with the fbi
or you know these his parents might get
might do harm to the teachers well well
actually this is fascinating one of the
core journalistic ethics is minimize
harm right but they only are now
applying it you take a look at cnn when
they were like here's the name of the
man who posted the nancy pelosi video
here's where he works right maximizing
harm against those who speak out against
their political ideology in this
instance we're not going to reveal who
this person is i'll give you a really
really good example of how this is is
manipulative in the mainstream press and
you know
he goes out and he reports on antifa
violence and extremism
he goes on twitter and he posts photos
of the people arrested at these
extremist events the left says he's
making kill lists he's secretly working
with the far right and then their allies
in media regurgitate the lies ryan
reilly of the huffington post has been
doing literally the exact same thing
about the january 6 defendants they
cheer him on as an intrepid and amazing
journalist doing the good good work of
exposing the extremists as far as i'm
concerned both of them are doing
journalism by saying here's the guy who
was charged here's why he was charged
i'm fine with either but you can see how
the political ideologies and you can see
how the mainstream media is willing to
support one
and oppose the other that's the murder
cult you can't attack the murder cult
and that's the thing is like you look at
everyday regular people and their
businesses their homes their property
their livelihoods
the government doesn't care about that
oh they've been decimated but if you go
after those guys on the shiny white
capitol hill you invade their space and
let's face it like those guys
they got more ammunition and and
firepower in their trucks that they left
behind and they didn't bring in there
and
like the fbi said there was no there was
no plan there's been a bunch of raucous
people who rioted it was bad like we all
yeah okay it was bad that's not cool
yeah i mean but that you know
you you have now stories that um they
don't track the leftist violence in the
same way they do the right you have the
hearings about how the right is
substantially worse this is the
fascinating thing i'm kind of i want to
loop this back to how they they frame
where itas on wikipedia are far right
what does that even mean when they don't
fight right
beside myself like i said in the
beginning of my
in the beginning of my i guess career i
used to fret and have sort of ptsd over
the wikipedia page i've come to accept
it
the moment you stop giving a [ __ ] about
what they think of you and stop seeking
their approval is the moment when you
become truly free i've learned this in
my life it's just i have to accept the
unacceptable to be labeled far right
i literally don't express my opinion
in any i've never expressed my opinion
in any of the investigations i've ever
done and all they do on television is
express their opinion i don't see
anything but them express their opinion
it's it's orwell's uh you know 1984
double thing well at least you haven't
been unpersoned uh on wikipedia they
they literally on person why did they do
that because i was exposing the russian
hoax right when it was uh the most
prominent in the mainstream media they
were saying there's clear russian
collusion russia hacked the election
they helped donald trump win and i'm
like no no no that didn't happen where's
the evidence we don't see any evidence i
don't believe in this story and because
of that wikipedia there was some editor
that wrote well even though they do
newsworthy stuff like get on epstein's
island or talk to this politician or
talk to this whistleblower we're going
to refrain from even naming them in any
future wikipedia entries uh and i was
like wait what i was like who's this
random user i forgot the user's name but
just completely unpursued me from
wikipedia i don't even exist on that
platform the last time i looked so
there's many different ways that they
try to go after you a lot of times they
try to silence you a lot of times they
attack you and i think they have to use
both because they know if they just
attack they sometimes make people grow
as well right they don't want to
mentions like voldemort right mario they
can't mention us by name or you know so
uh i i mean far right i i don't
and of course there's probably like how
many uh citations footnotes uh one two
three four five six seven eight nine
there's like all these opinion pieces
they're citing after that word
wikipedia
have you seen the uh larry sanger we had
him on the show once he was one of the
he's one of the co-founders of wikipedia
and he has just left his prop again at
this point it's crazy i used to donate
to wikipedia i was such a big fan this
idea of the community coming together
and being like let's get some good
reliable sources but i'll tell you this
even uh it's fascinating to me
when i look at media matters for
instance media matters is literally an
activist organization i mean i'm not
exaggerating or trying to insult them
they're an organization that scours
right-wing content or whatever you want
to call it and then disparages them
they've made they've made up things on
numerous occasions and newsguard which
is i believe funded by microsoft is uh
their their green green checkmark all
good all good speaking of media matters
this is a matter of headline last week
youtube is taking a victory lap for its
latest vaccine misinformation policy
meanwhile project veritas is gaining
millions of views on youtube
for quoting people uh so so media
matters is doing the yeoman's work of
trying to get us banned for doing
investigative reporting i i think you
should sue newsguard
newsguard yeah
so we use newsguard specifically because
i consider it a check on our bias
these are so newsguard is a factcheck
it's a rating agency they they have a 10
point system uh 100 point system and
veritas has a 57 out of 100 in their
scoring system they say the website
fails to adhere to several basic
journalistic standards which are those
they say you do not gather and present
information responsibly you not handle
the difference between news and opinion
responsibly really you don't disclose
owner ownership and financing and you
don't provide the names of your creators
along with either contact or biography
how do they rate
this right that's what i would have you
know what's funny i've never lost a
lawsuit project veritas has won every
single lawsuit and i will give ten
thousand dollars to any human being who
can name one deceptive edit in the last
decade of my life no one can do it but
they just keep saying i doctor tapes i
mean it's it's
i
it's become so cliche to say 1984. it it
doesn't even mean anything anymore but
it's like the double thing you know to
tell deliberate lies while genuinely
believing them to forget any fact that
becomes inconvenient and to draw it back
from oblivion when it becomes necessary
to do so to deny the existence of
objective reality it is what they do
and i
i keep saying this it's just pissing
everyone off such that there's going to
be an uprising here here's how it works
luke and i are sitting here
i report
uh
there is a court rose quartz crystal
ball here on the table right luke then
reports
you know tim poole is lying it's
actually a fluorite crystal ball what
happens then is you as the fact checker
can say either one of us is the liar
depending on which idea you want to
support so when i'm looking at the news
guard for ver for veritas you they
mentioned that you featured a postal
worker named richard hopkins right now
you actually did a story where he made
claims where he said things that's right
and you reported those things that's
right the mainstream media then called
you a liar they've decided the
mainstream media's claims are more valid
than yours thus you're not telling the
truth when they're literally trying to
decide between two people have made a
statement
just to say a word about that that
postal worker richard hopkins the
washington post
um uh richard hopkins was interrogated
by federal agents and richard hopkins we
had a recording of his interrogation we
published the recording
and then somehow the washington post was
leaked
statements by the federal agents well
there's only two federal agents in the
room and i know they're both of their
names and this and the federal agents
made claims
that contradicted the recording and the
washington post reports anonymously
sourced the people in the room
so they say and then cnn said well
credible sources say and i said well i
have the damn recording
i have the recording rock rock beat
scissors
i have the recording well but then and
jacob age of the uh of cnn literally you
could see the condescending smugness in
his face when he goes on anderson cooper
and says credible sources like the
washington well i have a recording of
what transpired so they're credible by
virtue of their own decree that they are
indeed credible it's a self-anointed
racket so this need this needs to go in
front of a judge is what i'm saying when
newsguard now says you are not credible
because the washington post has has has
pro with anonymous sources challenged
your actual recordings it needs to get
it to a judge where the judge can
determine is this is is this defamation
or is this is this libel it's written we
in day i i was just uh emailing my
colleague this and we did indeed send a
demand for a correction to um newsguard
to peggy ackerman's senior editor at
newsguard and we're in process of that
and and tim i have to sue a lot of
people i've been suing i mean i'm suing
twitter cnn new york times and we're
winning you know all the lawsuits it's
just
like i i think that luke your idea
people's defamation defense fund there
needs to be a hundred people suing the
new york times for defamation we've got
to find the right plaintiffs the right
set of facts to get past motion to
dismiss which is a very difficult burden
to get past uh tim but uh i agree with
you and i i will sue newsguard if they
don't
if they don't uh correct
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you